One of the most useful questions to ask
when you're building a low fidelity
prototype.
Is whether a user can easily make the
app do the thing it's supposed to do.
This may sound like a very
basic question, and it is.
But it's actually the most vital
thing to ask at this point.
For instance, one of the things
a user might want to do in
our example app is check off
a task they've completed.
We need to think about how a user will
achieve this task from the starting
point of, I have opened this app.
For a first time user, we may need
to have an instruction screen, but
in general there are three common
patterns for dealing with user flow.
The first is to have an app
that does only one thing and
so only have that one screen.
A good example of this is
your common calculator app.
The second is to have a main screen
that functions as a menu of options for
various things the user
can do in the app.
And then have each task
occur on its own screen.
Finally, you can have the first
screen of the app be a place where
the users can complete the most
common task the app will be used for.
And have a secondary screen for
the menu.
So, in our case,
we can't use the first pattern since
our app has multiple functions.
That leaves us with a choice between a
user flow which starts on a menu screen.
And having a user flow which starts on
a screen on which the user can check
off tasks.
As time has gone on, the second
pattern has become much more common.
It is generally better to be able to
isolate the most common use cases and
have those achievable from
the main screen like this.
For the same reason,
mobile notifications are best when the
user can perform some action directly
from the notification,
without opening the app itself.